all right it is one of the most unique
interesting and bizarre attractions we
have ever seen meow wolves omega mart is
the main draw at area 15 in las vegas so
get ready to step through a portal and
have your mind blown because we
definitely had our minds blown when we
went to see what this was all about
[Music]
we are here at area 15 meow wolf's omega
mark this is a store from another
dimension and you figure out the story
behind it how'd you go through now
everything in here is owned by dram corp
a fictional family-owned company are you
ready to shop i am ready to do this
nikki novak let's
go i've already seen so many things i
want to try drew what's going on man hey
all right drew's going to show us around
show us all the cool items that we can
eat okay yeah are we is this the cereal
absolutely every grocery store needs a
cereal aisle this one has simply spiders
i'm sorry it's actually simply does not
contain oh
okay i hate spiders in my cereal oh it
doesn't everyone you have to read the
fine print you know that's right there
hey what's our makeup mark all of our
products have the uncanny ability to
fulfill your desire so everything on
this aisle will help you
get through the maze absolutely okay
okay now i gotta figure out what my
secret desires are oh okay well it is
about to find out it's new year's eve
get it girl get it girl let's check out
some more products and you'll find out
what you're designing fantastic all
right where are we going next all right
let's go this way huh omega mart a lot
of favorites in here this is who told
you this was butter room fresh what's a
mega mart this is our 96 hour energy
drink
so this will get you through las vegas
and new year's eve there are portals
that will take you out of the grocery
store into dimensions beyond
so
you are going to open a portal for us
door number one
thank you vanna
whoa
this is so cool
where are we going
all right so you found your way through
a portal yeah into another dimension
feeling it
where are we right now all right right
now you're in the projected desert so
this is a hub that will lead you into
all sorts of different spaces i already
feel like i'm in a different space
emotionally
the fact that we're in the dram core
tunnel gives you an idea that we're
starting to move into some dram course
spaces in our fictional world i feel
like i'm in a drink a mega mart is just
a totally normal supermarket in las
vegas so we're going to find our way
into the next dimension do you think you
can help us get through those stop
that is so exciting i always wanted to
have one of these in my room come
sampling savings for yourself it's
almost over
i didn't want it to end it's never over
so you have tattooed chickens very
popular here at our meat counter we also
have all of the national monuments
carved in meats at the end so all sorts
of fun meat arrangements to experience
that was incredible thank you gerald oh
it's my pleasure thanks for letting us
share omegamar with and happy new year
let me tell you you have not lived until
you've tried tattoo chicken this is a
place that i cannot recommend highly
enough how much fun would we have it was
a lot of fun and they didn't show the
part where we went down the three-story
slide yes that
and you worked it and i loved it i did
it was so much fun i got to tell you
walking around that place it reminded me
of like a japanese game show where
everybody's a winner everybody's a dick
that's right meow wolf also has three
locations you can check out the one in
vegas which is absolutely amazing santa
fe mexico and they just opened one in
denver so check that out all right